there's hardly a morning goes by that we
don't talk about with issues or we don't
talk about stories and the the
newspapers that are talking about fat
jobs and high to lose weight and how to
keep fit and all that sort of thing well
we have got in the studio this morning
Whitney thore hire you Whitney yeah see
you and Whitney is from Greensboro North
Carolina and she's famous you you became
famous after being on YouTube and
basically it was a video entitled a fat
girl dancing it went viral millions and
millions and millions about 7 million
people knew her because of this let's
get on International first class seat on
my lap girl riding jumped above New York
to Haiti I got lipstick stamps on my
passport I make it hard to leave love on
the moon night tonight on the TLC
channel at 9 o'clock tonight and Whitney
has got a new series called my big fat
fabulous life and actually called
Whitney fat girl dancing here in the UK
it is it was so much for not okay so
you're still dancing yes yes and a lot
of people maybe say who you're kidding
really
your your your dancing here but really
this is this is not the sort of advert
that we should be be having hmm I think
that's interesting because my life isn't
an advertisement for anything I don't
have a hidden agenda I'm just living my
life the way that I see fit and fat
people so often offend others in society
and I find that it's one of the last
socially acceptable prejudices I I
absolutely agree with you on that one
but what about people who are concerned
about you I mean there might be people
concerned you're gonna keel over and die
because maybe your body your heart won't
be able to sustain all the enthusiasm
that you have that's true I do have a
lot of enthusiasm um I think that the
concern for health is often a mask
to discriminate or to be cruel to fat
people I think there are actually very
few people in my life who care and love
me enough to be genuinely concerned
about my health and as far as my health
goes I would like to break some
stereotypes about fat people because
even at 380 pounds I'm certainly not
naive to the health risks that may come
if I stay this weight but I have no
major health problems I've never even
had high blood pressure yet twit ly
right yet yet yet I do have to say I
advocate you I am overweight I am
constantly lampooned for being
overweight but I do speak to you from
concern you're doing your ankles no good
your knees no good your hips no good
your heart probably very no good so I
mean I do think there is concern people
would look at you and say who are you
sure but at least you're doing something
are you doing those moves to reduce your
width or just to say look I may be big
but I'm still going to enjoy myself yeah
why definitely like to lose about 100 or
150 pounds and I think what's
interesting is that so often people say
well she's so fat disgusting why is she
doing that why she exercising she's
killing her knees and I think well
what's the alternative what would you
rather me do right so it's it's it's um
in our society it's like that people
can't win if I go out and I exercise I
go to the gym I put my dance videos on
YouTube I just do what I want to do like
every other person deserves to I get
criticism for that but if I went oh my
god oh the praise you're also all yeah
you wouldn't have so many followers and
a lot of people in that position so do
you see yourself as a cheerleader for
them I do I mean the thing is I've
connected with so many people all over
the world men women young and old and
it's not specific just to body image I
hear from people who are anorexic as
much as I hear from people who are fat I
also hear from people who are gay people
who are disabled people who are dealing
with any kind of societal induced shame
and I think the first part to pursuing
health and happiness fully is to not be
ashamed of ourselves because I lost 10
years of my life when I was diagnosed
with polycystic ovarian syndrome and
gained over a hundred pounds to
depression and sadness and we cannot
pursue a holistic picture of health
which is mind body and spirit until we
are happy and unashamed and know that we
are worthy and deserving so I watch that
video and I feel inspired to get up and
dance to see someone that's having fun
and I think if it inspires other people
who might be in that
that you're talking about then I think
it's great thing I love the video I
couldn't dance like that
what are you that dancer did you take
time yeah briefly everyone hell yeah I
was a trained dancer right it's great
you can tell because it's an act so
you've got your program of TLC tonight
at 9 o'clock at what's next Dancing with
the Stars well you know I would love to
do that we'll have to see
I'll keep you posted Yeah right very
good Whitney thore thank you very much
indeed she is